Hola buenos días la Unión Europea y la
otan firman esta declaración para
intensificar la cooperación entre ambas
organizaciones se trata de la tercera
declaración que se produce pero que
tendría que haberse firmado en junio en
la histórica cumbre de la otan en Madrid
pero que finalmente se ha ido retrasando
y se ha producido hoy en que ambos ambas
organizaciones insisten en que se trata
de una declaración de Gran importancia
en un contexto en plena guerra en
Ucrania cuando pronto se va a cumplir un
año desde que estalló el conflicto ambos
bloques han asegurado que ahora más que
nunca la cooperación entre ambas
organizaciones es muy importante aun así
reconocen que aunque la otan es la base
de la defensa colectiva apoyan el
intento y también los esfuerzos por
parte de la Unión Europea para mejorar
también la defensa del bloque de los 27
en concreto en esta declaración se han
firmado para que se coopere más en
cuatro áreas Como por ejemplo en hacer
frente los ciberataques también al
terrorismo también las implicaciones
para la seguridad que tiene la crisis
climática Especialmente cuando se
desestabilizan regiones Como por ejemplo
la zona del sael que afecta directamente
a Europa pero también a toda la alianza
en también se va a fortalecer la
cooperación también en por ejemplo en
proteger infraestructuras hay críticas
como para evitar el caso de los
sabotajes de El gasoducto no Stream se
trata En definitiva de fortalecer una
cooperación que se ha ido forjando a lo
largo de los años pero que ahora tiene
más sentido que nunca a raíz de la
guerra en Ucrania pero que pasa
inevitablemente porque la Unión Europea
dependa aún más de la otan Esther
también Finlandia y Suecia siguen
esperando entonces ser miembros de esta
Alianza como estaba este proceso
Sí así es en los dos países nórdicos
siguen esperando pacientemente a pesar
de que pidieron su acceso el pasado mayo
un proceso que ha sido muy rápido pero
que a pesar de que prácticamente todos
los países lo han ratificado aún falta
dos especialmente Turquía y Hungría en
el caso de Turquía insiste en que
necesita más garantías de que ambos
países tanto Finlandia como Suecia no
protegen a miembros de organizaciones
kurdas consideradas terroristas por
ankara para el secretario general de la
otan y el stoltemberg Turquía tiene
preocupaciones legítimas pero que cree
que finalmente estos dos países acabarán
siendo miembros de pleno derecho más
pronto que tarde dentro de la alianza
aún así las dudas persisten para ancar a
que para este gobierno a una
insuficientes garantías y que hay que
tener en cuenta que ahora mismo el
presidente Turco y verdogan está en
plena campaña preelectoral por lo tanto
varias fuentes confirman que creen que
muy difícilmente
estos dos miembros tanto Finlandia como
Suecia puedan formar parte de la alianza
antes de la campaña electoral